let me play a little cat Williams too up
this cat anyway all right I was gonna
play a little cat Williams to get
everybody in the mood but uh I guess
he'll sit here and listen to it with us
Kat you want to sit and listen to some
of your stuff while uh we uh remind
people of some of your great comedy
stylings I know 50 Cent I made it real
cool to be shot let me just say I've
been shot before ain't [ __ ] cool about
it when I got shot ain't no [ __ ] come
out ain't no music play Nothing the [ __ ]
the park and I got shot I wasn't even in
the altercation I'm outside the club
watching some other [ __ ] look at these
crazy [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] got a gun [ __ ] be
good
is that a true story that you actually
got shot outside a club and you weren't
even involved yeah every every single
joke is the absolute truth it's the real
deal where did you get shot uh and what
part of the body in my thigh meat wow
you're lucky I mean yeah I mean you're
lucky to be alive yeah but I was unlucky
to be shot right that's true too you
know so it had to even out it really
sucks when you're minding your own
business and you get shot you don't mind
at least if you're getting shot I always
wonder though about the people who stand
around looking at trouble well see the
thing is you never know by the time you
find out it's trouble like there's a
very small space in between that's
trouble and the actual trouble really
yeah sometimes you catch it at the tail
end like you don't know they've been
arguing for 30 minutes you just walked
out you're not really aware of it things
happen in the course of seconds it gets
crazy yeah it thinks escalate although I
tell you what you got some big guys
around you everyone that was the talk
when you showed up here and everyone was
looking in the green room they were like
holy [ __ ]
you got big dudes I got a body Guardian
I think he's 64 years old and you should
see this guy probably terribly efficient
I wonder what the hell right now I was
talking about your bodyguard situation
the other day and I said yeah when I
find out he's like Mafia though like
Ronnie can be he's pretend Mafia Ryan's
an old Jew but how do you know you know
because soon as you walk in he's like
how you doing this he better be
connected he's doing this little kid you
need to sign this paper here
use your rest with the fishes when I met
Richard Pryor he you know he was already
you know in his I guess late 50s or
whatever and he had the oldest
bodyguards you know and you knew they
had been with him forever but these guys
weren't stopping anybody yeah
like those you had to get a musket
you wait 30 minutes to see what happens
to you let me load this [ __ ] up I'm
gonna shoot you
[Music]